what up guys welcome to the just
probably things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to omg
this is why men
fear marriage i want to get married
someday
so i gotta know why do men fear it let
me know in the comments if you guys fear
marriage yes or no
let me know if you're looking for
marriage a long-term relationship
or just you know hoes always trying to
get the mental perspective
before i start do not forget to
subscribe
hit that subscribe button you guys know
the spiel i try to keep it short and
sweet for you guys better marry my
oh wait let me start it from the let me
double check and make sure that the
audio is working
[Music]
parents are married they have been for
the last 20 years
um my my grandparents on my dad's side
are married my parents
i mean my grandparents on my mom's side
they're not but
i feel like what makes or what made me
angry that i'm working through
is my example of men because
when i hear my mom talk about my
grandfather who i didn't get to
experience it's
not what i see in my dad so i was angry
with him for a little while
and then i got over that well i'm
working through that so i think i got
over it
but um when i listen to your show
and even tonight i hear what you're
saying in regards to
you know women should focus on like
their fitness and being feminine and
cooperative and
all of those things but
it still seems like we're still at
a disposition like i still have to work
against
that narrative okay
ma'am you threw a lot at me at one time
you bribed me i know your parents your
mother and father
everybody i wanted to give you
background how old are you
26. all right um
did you have braids how are you 26 i'm
still
like mad at your parents i mean
i get it when you first go off to
college and whatever you're like i want
to get out of the house
do my own thing i'm done you guys are
terrible but
if your parents were like halfway decent
i mean i'm not talking about people with
parents that were like actually bad but
anyways i'm going to keep going say that
one more time
okay 26 i'm trying to remember okay
you got to work you got to work at what
is frustrating
that you have to work against what
i feel like i have to work against the
narrative that is set
for black women that we are just angry
and loud and upset and
pretty much everything that you're you
kind of talk about in your show all
right all right
so the narrative is it a narrative or
does it play itself
why okay
well there's part narrative but then you
have to ask
yourself you live reality um or
i i took that little straw poll are
black women
happy are the majority of black women
happy or angry today
that's right i would say the majority
are unhappy
why
why would you say like a better word the
circumstances that we put ourselves in
the women that i've seen on his show
that he's talked to
seem to be unhappy because of bad life
choices
and i don't think that's in particular
to black women in general
um i think that's any race like
bad life choices lead to unhappiness
any time i've been in a situation that
i really didn't want to be in or i
wasn't happy with my life it was because
of the life choices that i
made right okay but if
okay so it's not a narrative if it's the
majority is true man
i understand that
okay i understand that but i my
confusion
or not even confusion where the
disconnect for me
is someone like myself where i am
working to improve
different areas that i see are
weaknesses
that are my own and that i've learned
through the behavior of the women in my
life and watching their marriages
okay but that's what i mean by how's
your boyfriend
okay so where's your boyfriend or
husband
[Music]
um i actually just broke up with them my
boyfriend how long how long
were you guys together we were together
for about five months
five and a half okay uh who broke it off
i did do you guys think six months is a
long time
because i'll hear kevin samuel say
that's not a long time but i'll also
hear him say that you should be engaged
in six months so let me know in the
comments
why i wasn't happy
so but it's with myself let me just go
ahead and let me
go ahead and just level say you said
you're 26
yes let me just go ahead and level set
you man i have to work three times as
hard to get half the credit and guess
what
that's just my lot in life there's
always going to be prejudice
and uh discrimination and unfair
treatment
to any human being do you know what one
of the best like
um privileges there is pretty privilege
literally like
attractive people get less sentences
more than anything there's a difference
is you either going to work to overcome
it
or you're going to let it overcome you
that's it
and it won't be the latter well then the
thing is if you say that
see the thing is the being
you shouldn't be angry about the truth
well it's not fair nor so angry
well if it what are you gonna do about
it though
because here's another thing
black women are under whose burden
[Music]
whose burden are you under
because it can't be black men
no it it feels like
[Music]
what i see and what i see is like my
parents relationships for my mom
or my grandparents no no no no no no no
okay your mom's relationship your
grandparent's relationship or their
relationship
you're a grown woman it's time for your
own graces
i agree i do so but you're still
bringing it up but when you tell me that
you
were mad at your father because he's not
your grandfather the first thing i'm
saying is
the nerve of you the first thing i'm
saying is the nerve of you
should your father have been unhappy
with you cause you ain't your sister
damn damn
listen you have no problem women black
women in general have
never had a problem judging black men
even the ones that you should not judge
he's your father
i don't feel like i'm taking the the
approach of being
like judgmental like you're wrong i'm
not saying that but i am
observing what i grew up around my
environment
and i'm not saying that my dad
or your mother and father i'm not taking
anything okay but hold on will your
mother and father marry
yeah they're married they're still
married to this day right and did you
graduate high school
i'm sorry did you graduate from high
school yeah did you go to college
i did did you graduate from college i
did
so your father raised a college graduate
he did
what the french toast are you talking
about that's better than most of the
country
damn it sounds like yo and he's still
married to your mother
sounds like he did a hell of a job to me
that's why i also said i'm not taking
anything from him but you said you were
mad at me
you said no no no you said you were matt
you i just don't understand how you
could be 26
and still talking about this you know
how long it's been since you've been out
of the house
19 20 21 oh my god i can't do bad
eight years eight years what are you
doing lady
earlier you said that there was a time
when you were upset
and mad at right angry and then and the
nerve of you
to look a gift horse in the mouth you
got what 8 out of 10 black people don't
have a father in the household
but as usual black men still ain't good
enough so you make an issue ain't no god
damn judging your father because he
wasn't your grandfather
when you got more than what most kids in
the neighborhood had a dad
a dad that was apparently good enough to
stay married to your mama raised a
colleague a high school and a college
graduate
wow damn
and black men hear this [ __ ] black men
hear this
and they're like well what the [ __ ] else
are we supposed to do
being married to a black woman and
raising those and providing a lifestyle
to where you graduated from high school
in college and didn't end up on drugs on
the street in the penitentiary
whole house babies all over the world
what the [ __ ] else is the black man
supposed to do
a white man could just go to work in the
plant and that's good enough a black man
got to go build the goddamn plant
and his kids still ain't happy i'm not
laughing i am not
[ __ ] laughing um i am because
i'm not angry in that way
but i am like black men are because i
listened to what you
said you were angry with your father for
what reason because he wasn't another
man
you don't know your grandfather you
weren't raised there so all you had was
stories that your mama told you
and that's the thing people don't
realize the stories that you hear about
people
especially if they're passed away like
people aren't talking about the
negatives about them
so you take the stories that your mama
told you versus what your daddy was
doing
and got the nerve to get mad at your dad
well how did he feel because he couldn't
be the man you thought your grandfather
was
do you ever ask me how you felt about
that we did yeah we
have had quite a few conversations and
how did he feel
of course
but i it wasn't just because of the
comparison to my grandfather and the
comparisons came from
what i felt like my mom did receive that
i was fighting for my dad which was his
intention i feel like he was able to be
more present with my brothers at the
time than he was with me growing up
which was a part of our conversation
that you're asking about and
from his standpoint he gave me how did
your mother and how did your mother and
how did your mother balance out these
things
my mom gave me a lot of the things that
i feel like i'm working through now like
the i'm not trying to push put it all on
my dad that's why i said like the women
because i noticed how how she also
treated and behaved with my dad and
everybody but you did what you did not
mention is that you were upset and angry
with your mother
we just didn't get to that part
you didn't sleep with it i had to pull
it from you this
time no okay i wasn't
instead of saying you know what
you make some good points she just keeps
going and keeps defending herself
and you don't ever know the ins and outs
of a family but like
she sounds very bratty right here
all right and here's another thing all
right granted but here's the thing
first world problems
you sound really entitled man
you had a mother and father who was
still married
did they provide for apparently they
provided for all your needs
and this is what i i've tried to explain
to certain like family members
is they'll be mad because you know we
had like
nannies growing up right and like you
know sometimes my parents weren't around
that much but i look
back and all my friends today are
struggling with college debt
you know what i have zero of college
debt because my parents were gone all
the time
like everything you do in life is a
trade-off
and you worried about your wants i
didn't get what my brother's got
oh my god the second i don't think that
that's wrong for
a little girl yes it is no no
that's not rhonda it's not wrong to want
love but it's all but
oh this this is why i say first world
problems
there's disney vacation to where the man
did the best he
freaking could and it still wasn't good
enough because the youthful year the
years his daughter should have been
praising and loving our father
you were angry with him because he
didn't give you what you felt you
deserved
i wasted some years when i was younger
like being mad
at you know my dad for being gone
she was gone like a lot growing up like
i kind of feel what
she's saying but it's part of maturity
realizing that your parents
literally do the best they can and being
really
thankful for all that they do for you
rather than presenting them for the
small things that maybe they didn't do
shoulda got or what your mama got
oh my god
when you have children
i'm sorry
i didn't hear the question you asked uh
i hope when you have children
you don't have to experience that level
of hurt
as a parent with an ungrateful child
and some of you ladies don't seem to
realize that this is how so many men
feel defeat they only want to try
let me go ahead and say this this is why
many men don't even want to try to do
relationships or get married anymore
because they hear this that this woman
came from an intact grandparent
nuclear family lived a
life presumably middle class parents
are still married but because she didn't
get the kind of love that
she felt she needed or deserved or
wanted
[Music]
and it hurt men are saying
that's what i got to look forward to to
get out and go work my ass to death
to provide to stay on the straight and
narrow to be faithful
to end up with that to have a
yeah he has a point
[Music]
you ever think about how lucky we are
just not to be
raised when like the plague was going on
and just to be born in like the century
that we're born in where we have so much
more opportunity especially as women
like
if you don't want to be you don't have
to be a housewife anymore and that
really
there wasn't that much like opportunity
outside of that before
anyways let me know in the comments um
do you think that the lady had like any
entitlement or do you think that
i mean entitlement to like feel the way
that she did or do you think
that maybe like like do you agree with
kevin
sorry i'm thinking slow today let me
know in the comments don't forget to
like share
comment and subscribe bye guys